FRANCOIS DESCHENES:
The watch face
is one of the most
prominent UI components
of Wear OS by Google.
As a developer, you can create
your own custom watch faces
and share your creations
in the Google Play Store.
I am Francois, and
I will walk you
through the high level
design and development
steps of the watch face.
To kick off, let's take a look
at the different components
of a watch face.
At its most basic, a watch
face is an expression of style
and provides a way to tell time.
Beyond this, there is also
what we call complications.
It's a traditional
watchmaking term
denoting areas of the
watch face that show
information other than time.
In this example, the watch
face is showing the date.
With Wear OS by Google
being a connected platform,
watch face developers
can take full advantage
of data supplied by
the system itself
or other apps
installed on the watch.
This enables watch
face developers
to display bite-sized
information right
from the watch face, such
as the current temperature
or other information
that the user chooses.
Although supporting
complications is technically
optional for watch
face developers,
we have seen strong user
demand for this feature,
and it is very much recommended.
Lastly, Wear OS has two modes
of operations, interactive mode
and ambient mode.
In interactive mode, the user
will expect the watch face
to be in full color and
ready for user interaction.
In ambient mode, the watch face
should light up no more than 5%
of the screen pixels and should
avoid solid blocks of color
to prevent screen burn
in on OLED display.
In addition, the
screen is not expected
to be updated more
than once a minute.
So remember to remove any
indication of seconds while
in this mode.
Now that you have a design,
it's time to start coding.
The easiest way
to get started is
to create a new project
in Android Studio.
Select Wear OS as the form
factor, and select Watch Face.
After you have completed
the setup wizard,
you will have a startup project
with a functioning watch face
that you can customize.
In the generated
code, I would like
to highlight three methods
that developers should
pay particular attention to.
The first one is
onSurfaceChanged.
This method is run once at the
start of watch face creation,
and it has access to
the screen dimensions.
As a result, this
is the perfect time
to resize any bitmap
you might have
or adjust the size of
your watch face features.
The second method is onDraw.
This is where the watch
face rendering code lives,
and it runs every
time a frame is drawn.
As a result, you should pay
attention to its performance.
Avoid expensive operations,
such as loading and resizing
resources.
Last, but not least,
onAmbientModeChanged.
This is called whenever the
watch face enters or exits
ambient mode.
You can use this method to
change and swap paint objects
before rendering the screen.
As we mentioned before,
Wear OS complications
are a powerful way
to help the user stay
connected by providing
bite-sized information
on the watch face.
We have a suite of APIs
to enable your watch face
to connect to
external data sources
and help you render them
using complication drawables.
To find out more,
follow this code lab.
With great power comes
great responsibility.
Watch faces are one of the
most prominent UI components
of the Wear OS platform.
At the same time, this
means your watch face
will very likely be run for
most of the device uptime.
Any inefficiency or
errors will severely
impact battery user experience.
Before you publish your
watch face, please use it
extensively for a long period
of time to catch any issues.
Pay particular attention to when
the watch is an ambient mode,
that it is not doing more
processing than it needs to.
Any rogue code could
severely impact battery life.
Watch faces offer an
opportunity to create something
very personal, and there
is something special
about seeing your own watch
face for the first time
on your Wear device.
Why not see it for yourself?
This might just be the
wearable platform for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]